Rolling Stones top singers have some
real hum dingers and what the hell do
you mean listing great voices without
miscellane geriatric magazine Rolling
Stones released their list of 200
greatest singers of all time and it's so
bad it makes music fans wish the
magazine would stick to making up
stories about ivermectom and sexual
assault
Rolling Stone previously shared their
100 greatest singers list back in 2008
and 98 of them were Bob Dylan
well they weren't yes they were and now
just about everyone who ever sang a song
made the list even the cat who sang the
Meow Mix jingle made the cut
[ __ ]
but what's outraging music fans and
Twitter fans alike is the absence of one
Legend and that Legend is Celine Dion
one of the top selling solo artists of
all time and that's according to my gay
staff members
and even evil Shannon bream tears up
when they play My Heart Will Go On I
didn't think she even had emotions
they don't have the guy from aha listen
I'ma stop you right now they had Prince
16 list they're stupid okay all right
and where was Michael Jackson yeah he
said that was on there yeah not number
one I mean number one Aretha Aretha
Franklin was number one no Aretha it was
such a force and she did all of it by
while being tracked by the FBI for 40
years yeah
number one going on Rolling Stone to
find out about music is like going to
MTV to watch a video it just doesn't
happen anymore it's just a it's a
left-wing weirdo and they only like
Adele beat out people like it's
ridiculous no I'm gonna tell you you
know the guy Prince was 16 I was done
you know who you know who beat Glenn
Danzig Glenn Danzig was at 199. I can't
believe he was even on it I know Misfits
it's pretty amazing yeah you know who
else who's on it wait wait wait wait let
me finish you know who beat Glenn Danzig
do you know who beat Glenn Danzig Neil
Young oh Neil can't sing young that's
crazy yeah oh I've never listened to
Neil Young I like this no no it's an
accidental Harvest dude it's a classic
album his sacrifice on Spotify was
rewarded yeah yeah you made the list oh
that's right that's right
um Billy ellish also beat Glenn Danzig
what are we doing here she might be a
better singer than Glenn dad but I love
Glenn Danza that's not me knock this is
what bothers me about this story people
if I get one message across tonight this
is it please learn what the word snubbed
means yes I'm tired of seeing the word
snubbed in headlines like this Celine
Dion getting left off of a list that
doesn't mean anything to anybody is not
getting snubbed when I wasn't talking to
you backstage
that was a good snub it was true it's
true though like if I don't go to shake
your hand that's a snub getting left out
of a thing that doesn't it just means
you didn't get included that's not what
it's like she's comforted by the
billions of dollars you know but I have
to ask you know I'm still having my snub
joke work it was really good I think it
was a light lap it wasn't out of control
after like what'd they do for me I know
you would
no Mike Patton
he would never be on that Joe Mike
Patton he's the greatest singer of all
time I I agree but he would never be on
that I can't I'm still in shock that
Glenn Danzig got onto the list that's
incredible but that makes up for Celine
being left off why do people Prince is
16. why are we talking about it yeah
wait hold on do you think Prince should
be one you know I think this is
difference between people who could sing
a song that somebody else wrote and
songwriters artists musicians yeah when
you're the total package and you stand
up to the well that's why because he did
the slave thing for a while but yeah
sorry yeah Prince was 16. I'm taking my
ball and going home you know he's not I
did not carry him through a club for his
safety
there you have it
they had lots interior of the cramps not
on the list one of the greatest
rockabilly singers of all time I mean
how deep cut do you want to go no it's
just that I I am mad at myself for
actually being that interested in
obvious click bait we know that the
Rolling Stone as an entity is dead I
grew up reading Rolling Stone I Put pic
pose I put the covers on my wall of like
Cheap Trick In The Glass it's a hateful
snide terrible publication but I still
get suckered in well once the covers got
small then you knew it was over it was
over that's the turning point with
rolling stone judge what is what what
did you what was your key takeaway my
key takeaway is that Minnie Riperton
does not belong on a list of the top 200
singers oh my she's a great singer
Minnie Riperton
you're beautiful
[Applause]
that's right
[Applause]
now I was Minnie on there and Celine
Dion isn't where was Sammy Davis on the
list oh I don't know or Sammy Hagar no
Celine Dion should be on it though this
is like performers too and then I have a
friend well I guess we have a friend who
loves Celine Dion so much that when
anyone says anything bad about Celine
Dion he recoils as if you just hit him
in the face yeah exactly no it is an
outsized reaction that people have to
something so strange like singing
singing probably just evolved as a way
as a mating ritual right to sort of like
get more mates you say order run from
something trying to eat I mean that is
literally what birds do yes that said
well the birds and the bees well the
birds sing is actually violent oh this
is my area you come over here I'll kill
you your sparrows are murderers hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else